heute befassen wir uns mit Peter Singer
eine noch lebenden australischen
Philosophen der ein Buch geschrieben hat
mit dem Titel practical Epics das ist
erstmals 1979 erschienen gibt es auch in
Deutschland Besetzung wir lesen jetzt
einige zentrale Zitate daraus auf
Deutsch und wir haben ein paar
Leitfragen zum einen inwiefern ist der
Utilitarismus nach singer von einem
universalen Standpunkt aus plausibel wie
unterscheidet sich Peter singers und
teletarismus zum klassischen
hotelitarismus also von
Jeremy Bentheim gmur Henry City
natürlich
Subjekte müssen für den Utilitarismus
nach Singen berücksichtigen werden sind
es nur Menschen menschliche Personen
vernünftige Wesen oder vielleicht auch
nicht menschliche Tiere das wird die
Frage sein singer sagt zu Beginn der
universale Aspekte Ethik liefert uns
eine überzeugende die wohl nicht letzte
gültige Begründung dafür eine
infinitaristische zu tun im weiteren
Sinne einzelnen also wenn wir Ethik als
universal verstehen dass sie alle
gleichermaßen betrifft ohne Unterschied
dann müssen wir satt singer ein
unterlidarismus wählen die Begründung
ist folgende indem ich akzeptiere das
moralische Urteile von einem universalen
Standpunkt aus getroffen werden müssen
akzeptiere ich das meine Interessen
nicht einfach deshalb weil sie meine
Interessen sind mehr zählen als die
Interessen von irgendjemand anderen
daher muss ich wenn ich moralisch denke
mein ganz natürliches Bestreben das für
mehr ein Interessen gesorgt wird
ausgedehnt werden auf die Interessen
anderer also es geht letztendlich singen
darum
den Utilitarismus von Begriff des
Interesses eher zu denken nicht so sehr
vom Lutz
berücksichtigt vergrößert werden die
Interessen oder die interessensziele die
die jeweiligen Lebewesen haben und nicht
der nutzen nur das ist zu seine
Modifikation er sagt angenommen ich
beginne dann soweit moralisch zu denken
dass ich erkenne dass meine eigene
Interessen nicht einfach aus dem Grund
weil sie meine Interessen sind mir
erzählen als die Interessen andere
anstelle meine eigenen Interessen habe
ich nun Interessen aller zu
berücksichtigen die von meinen
Entscheidungen betroffen sind dieser
fordert von mir dass ich alle diese
Interessen Abwege und jeden
Handlungsverlauf wähle von dem es am
wahrscheinlichsten ist dass er die
Interessen der Betroffenen weit ist
gehen befriedigt also muss ich sagen
sehr wenigstens auf einer bestimmten
Ebene meinem moralischen Überzeugung den
Handlungsverlauf während der persaldo
also
abgewogenermaßen am Ende im Endeffekt
für alle Betroffenen die besten
Konsequenzen an so weit ist er natürlich
noch auf der Spur des klassischen
Utilitarismus müssen uns jetzt fragen
was er davon eine inwiefern eine andere
Einstellung erwählt er sagt die hier
skizzierte Denkweise ist eine Form von
Utilitarismus die unterscheidet sich vom
klassischen hotelitarismus darin das
beste Konsequenzen das bedeutet was
Perso die Interessen der Betroffenen
fördert und nicht bloß das was löst
vermehrt und Lust verringert das war bei
Bentheim und mir eher der Fall
es geht also um die Tressen die müssen
befördert werden die müssen gestärkt
werden die müssen berücksichtigt werden
und da wo die meisten Interessen
berücksichtigt werden da ist die
Handlung orange am besten Single kommt
dann noch auf das Prinzip der gleichen
Interessensabwägung zu sprechen er sagt
es funktioniert wie eine Waagschale
Interessen werden unparteiisch abgewogen
echte Wagen begünstigen die Seite auf
der das Interesse stärker ist oder
verschiedenen interessens sich zu einem
Übergewicht über eine kleinere Anzahl
ähnliche Interessen einbinden aber sie
nehmen keine Rücksicht auf das wessen
Interessen sie ablegen entscheidend
das sagt nämlich das Prinzip der
gleichen Interessensabwägung verbietet
es unsere Bereitschaft die Interessen
andere Person abzulegen von ihren
Fähigkeiten oder anderen Merkmalen
abhängig zu machen außerdem einen das
sind Interessen haben es geht also um
interessensfähige Wesen Interesse
schließen könnte man sagen die
berücksichtigt werden müssen es geht um
die Extension des Nutzens also wer muss
berücksichtigt werden um die Extension
der Gemeinschaft der in den
Utilitarismus
einzubeziehenden Subjekte nicht um die
Intention nicht um die Bedeutung der
Gemeinschaft sondern die Frage welche
Individuen darunter fallen und eine
solche Interessensgemeinschaft und da
sagte eben dann am Ende dass da auch
nicht menschliche Tiere unterfallen ich
schlage vor sagte dass wir wenn wir das
Prinzip der Gleichheit als eine
vernünftige moralische Basis für unsere
Beziehung zum Mitgliedern unserer
Gattung nämlich Menschen akzeptiert
haben auch verpflichtet sind es als eine
vernünftige moralische Basis
verlebewesen zu den außerhalb unsere
Beziehung zu den außerhalb unserer
Gattung anzuerkennen den nicht
menschlichen Lebewesen deswegen hat auch
Peter Singer eine Tierethik verfasst
animals die auf diesen Prinz nutzen
Interessen unter die Terrassen muss
passiert
ja vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
wir sitzen dann die Diskussionen